all right Garrett I'm back yes you are
great to see you again yes you too I
I've had a lot happen since my last
interview and I felt like
I don't know I needed to come on here
and not clarify things but just kind of
like
I don't know let's get into it you told
me you've been through a lot
yeah so I've had a lot happen and it
kind of was like a full circle moment
for me where you had asked me questions
in my last interview specifically about
you know if I was involved in like drugs
and like substances and literally like
right after that interview I kind of
found myself
at my lowest point and doing and trying
um really hard you know drugs for money
um
again it was just kind of like an
obsession with money being a sugar baby
and can you explain how you're doing
drugs for money because I think people
probably don't understand oh yeah so
basically
um well for me it was always people
contacted me with like the term party
and play which most of the time is like
Tina
um crystal meth could yeah it's like
even hard for me like fathom that like I
did that because that's something
obviously no one like
grows up saying yeah I'm gonna do that
one day but um
yeah and DMT just literally like some
stuff I don't even know ketamine
um but yeah so basically sugar daddies
and clients would message me if I wanted
to do that and you would always get a
lot more money if you did that because
you know
because they're doing it because they're
doing it and I kind of I guess
understand the
attractiveness of you know being
intimate with someone when you're both
just completely just you know so far
gone you don't do it exactly
um but I
have been fortunate so far that I've
never had to
go that low for myself
and I just became so obsessed with money
and I was at a point where I was
literally doing it didn't matter anymore
like what I just wanted money I love
expensive things and I've had this like
you know this Envision this lifestyle
for myself and there's nothing basically
that was taught me from getting it
yeah what I've learned after
interviewing so many sex workers mostly
female is that once you connect
sex and money
they kind of stay connected forever yeah
and that's bad because it's
like I If people I a lot of like I guess
not normal people but people view like
sex is just like you know like an
intimate fun thing but me like it's tied
to money like it's yeah it's very hard
for a person I think who is who's has
been selling their bodies for sex and it
goes as far like too like in person and
also like only fans I do it digitally
too like online through the phone so
it's just like
for the squares Among Us that
have sex for with people we we love yeah
and that's it that's the that's the only
part of the equation that matters yeah
we can't even understand how like
selling sex where money is
a thing that just sticks and yeah yeah
and that's how it actually started um so
basically like I had done the interview
with you and I had mentioned in that
interview like I wanted a boyfriend I've
never had one before because I'm still
21 and
um I had someone actually
trying to be a little bit careful with
my words like I guess booked me for my
time
um and he was super young and well off
and
like young enough to where I was like
like I would have done this for free
basically like he was attractive and we
went to dinner um
but yeah paying me tons of money and
then I later found out that he also
was escorting and she had a huge list of
clientele but obviously his demographic
was a straight man I'm a very like
feminine boy I'm you know Trans in the
process of transitioning and um
so it was kind of like
the things that he was doing was very
different than mine but together that
was almost like a power Duo and on top
of him you know buying me so much
designer and stuff like that like I felt
crazy in love and I'm a Pisces
um so I love very hard and we got into
like my childhood trauma you know in my
last interview so like love is something
like again like I will do anything for
it to even if it harms me
and um yeah but anyways that's how I got
involved in this because his clients
were paying so much money like so much
and I was kind of Blown Away at the
numbers
and he was like you know like
not pressuring me but kind of like if
you wanted like let's do this together
like we'll be making a ton of money and
a lot of that was the partying and
playing
um you know in penthouses and houses in
the Hills I was in New York
um for two months with him
and that was like my first time kind of
like really diving into I guess this
industry like not in LA because I've
really just tried to you know make as
many connections here as I can
since I live here
um and I found myself in a very very
dark place and I honestly like
if I did not get help like I had like I
have I I don't even know like what my
life would be like right now and it's
it's crazy how much change in within
like a four month period
you're walking a slippery slope here
very yeah your age yeah and your little
subculture exactly and I I felt like
because I've done like other like shows
and stuff like TV shows and I feel like
I've glamorized there are nice things
about being the Sugar Baby Ken doll or
whatever the Persona you know I put on
but um
it was very dark very demonic
um
I don't even remember a lot of things
like there were
the most random men entering these
houses
and I just I don't even remember what
was happening to me
um
I don't know I just get very emotional
thinking that I put myself through a lot
of this stuff
um
yeah I don't know it's very demonic too
like I literally woke up and they were
upside down crosses and candles
literally around me the Satanic Bible
was playing like if like it just goes to
show like how far or like how messed up
these drugs can like make people and how
because you feel Invincible when you're
on it
um
and yeah it's very demonic and I felt
like I've LED that energy into my life
um I was self-harming myself which I've
never done
um and by then I mean like cutting and
stuff and you know contemplating
killing myself
um and that was in this period of I was
doing this every day these drugs and
stuff and
when I wasn't on them like I I felt
literally like my entire life was
falling apart
and you're currently
where are you at currently are you are
you still using are you no I'm
never and I never did these things
um I'd say outside of working besides
drinking like I do drink a lot and I
kind of self-reflected on that
um drinking is like one thing like I
basically do every single night alone to
fall asleep it just calms me down but
it's gotten kind of bad
um but I I have not done
tea is like the main thing I would say
that like
um
I don't think I got to the level of
addiction but it was definitely the urge
was starting to become like wow like I
kind of want this again and that feeling
um
I don't want to make it sound too
appealing but what is the attraction to
crystal meth
um
I'd say
I don't know that's the thing like
someone's in here like I don't know
different stories from different people
yeah again some of them claiming it's
the best sex drug ever and other yeah I
was gonna say for sex like obviously
like
the things I let happen to myself and I
even if
that's the thing like I even if I didn't
want people to do these things to me
they would have anyway and I would have
just let it go because you're just so
like you're so loose and everything
feels incredible
um I know a lot of people say like he'll
make anyone gay like it truly like um
you just have no limits and that's the
problem with it you have no limits at
all I think it's in jail or in prison
they call it queer juice
that makes sense it really does because
a lot of these clients like of course
with me are like oh well I like every
hour sleep I've got I've slept with a
guy before or anything like that and
then
I don't know crazy attracted to me when
they're on it for sure
um and I don't know I I really felt like
I needed to come on here and say this
because I sensed this I feel like I
completely want to I call it a persona
but it's not a persona but just the
whole Kendall thing but um I
completely getting out of this industry
100 percent you are
um it it's very dark and I don't
really want to glamorize it because now
I truly can see how dark
um this is and
once things fell apart in that
relationship I found myself being left
in their pits basically because I had
never done any of this before
and I was at my lowest and using and
it kind of just left and I was like this
is actually scary how
um
I'm trying to think it's just scary how
far I basically went went for like money
and love and was just kind of left at
the end with nothing and the other
person was outweighed before me you know
and I was still kind of like
I don't does it make sense what I'm
saying I'm not Indiana anymore
what you're not in Indiana anymore no
exactly and that's the thing like I
I grew up with that even with my own not
like my parents but my extended family
like using and stuff and
like my Aunt Leonard had a stroke to do
some math and stuff like that and like
if that was something I'd always said I
will never do and that's the thing
um it's an incredibly popular drug yeah
all over the country and it's it's scary
because it's the person you become on it
it's like wow like it I don't know it
makes you zombie almost like a very like
freaky zombie
um
but yeah I
and the only reason I felt like I did it
again for the money but it's almost like
I wasn't like out in the streets doing
it it was in you know multi-million
dollar houses they were
high profile people these were people in
the industry like it doesn't it's weird
when you almost put like
um
I guess like a social class
when you like factor in like a social
class doing drugs like it it almost
seems more appealing to do it because
it's like oh well these people are rich
and they're doing it and it's an
interesting dynamic because on your
channel like a lot of the people I feel
like
so far like are like um on the streets
and Stefan are using and I feel like I
have a
um an approach in a perspective of you
know super well-off people and they're
completely strung out like every day
like they they're like not right in the
head like some of these people because
they're using so much
um and yeah that's it was like I guess
that was the appealing aspect of it to
me but you've gotten clean yes I have
not done how did you do that
well I mean I started going to therapy
I've never done because like I had said
in my last
um interview like I went to conversion
counseling so therapy was always kind of
something that because that was a form
of therapy even though I was kind of you
know forced against my will to go just
the whole idea of therapy kind of um
it always
um
I don't know I always just I hate the
word triggered but it kind of like
triggered me you know
um and basically I mean you just have to
kind of just sit there and just block
out I I stopped talking to all the
people who I was doing it with
um that person leaving my life
um that I loved like that that it just
woke me up
um also like I'm currently moving you
know where I live and I felt like
I just need a new energy all around
um
and I don't know I I have very good
self-control I feel like so when I want
to quit something and that's the thing I
feel like I was right at that Peak or
that point of if you continue this
it's gonna be an addiction and your life
will be over and destroyed
um or you can wake up and realize you're
21 like there's literally no need like
there are so many other things I can do
in life
that could bring me just as much success
and money
um and yeah I don't know I just think I
grew up really fast and
I love expensive things
and you're living in a fast City dot to
a fast City but I can't leave La
um I did think about it I was like you
know what maybe like the cornfields
aren't so bad because it is just like a
slower
um faster pace of living here and you
just don't sometimes realize like how
much you're losing yourself throughout
you know it yeah a lot of people come up
come to LA from Indiana or somewhere
smaller town across the country and they
they get swallowed up exactly and I was
getting swallowed up like for that
moment
I don't know and it's very sad that I
let myself get that far and I just want
to if there's like younger you know
people watching this who
like oh like I want to be a sugar baby
and stuff like that like
it's honestly just run like it it can be
it's also really hard because there's a
lot of especially if you get connected
with higher profile people like there's
a lot more power that they have over you
and there were situations that have
happened during these nights
um there could even there's been issues
with just like money and stuff like that
to where it's like they know where I
live
um I've had people show up at my door
knocking at like 3 A.M and it's very
scary
um and I just kind of need to learn like
I need to protect myself more
and not just let anyone into my home
um because you know sometimes I was
letting people over at my place not
always just going to theirs yeah because
last time you painted a picture of
being a sugar baby is something really
fun lucrative and appealing yeah and I
still like
don't necess like I've had great
opportunities in life and I know I'll
continue to but
um it can be amazing but I feel like I
it it's just so weird how the world
works like literally right after I did
that interview is when I I got thrown
into the dark side of it and I feel like
it almost in escorting and I feel like
um
and I kind of feel like it's that thing
where it's like
um
you know you'll get something but as
humans like we always want more and I
feel like if you get into being a sugar
baby like
it yeah it can be like all fun and cute
at first but I feel like eventually
you're gonna get to that point like I
did where
this you're like well this still isn't
enough like I want more and you
and that's the thing about me if I want
something in life I will get it I can be
very crazy in that way of I don't have
limits
um so yeah I I was like you know what
whatever like I'll just put my body and
myself through
these experiences and substances and
buy more mugler and you know in the
morning but um
yeah it was it's been very dark for sure
so what does the future hold for you now
you mentioned you want to transition
yeah I do
um I started transitioning like four
months ago you know taking
estrogen and there's like three pills
that I'm on and um your goal is to be
I want to look like a CIS woman for sure
I'm like and I feel like it almost
in a way and I know this is going to
maybe offend people but this is just me
like um
and not offend people but I feel like
people might call me crazy but people
call me that anyway
um
I almost I've always kind of felt like
I've wanted to transition because I have
a very feminine body and just the
demographic of guys I like love you know
I feel like things I wouldn't always be
the secret
if I looked CIS like out in public but
um
I'm almost kind of embarrassed I'm
getting to that point where I'm almost
embarrassed of everything I've kind of
put out online and stuff with being a
sugar baby and I kind of just want to
transition and
become a new person and you know my name
is Garrett like leave kind of Garrett
behind Sugar Baby Ken doll I did think
it would be like cute if like once I
transition my name was Kendall like
Kendall Jenner but like let's play on
Ken doll but I I just don't even think
I'll do that
probably dye my hair like brunette like
natural and your goal is to be
to have some male parts but yeah I want
to be fully done up as a woman but I
don't want to like cut my dick off I
feel like that you said it I didn't say
it yeah yeah
which seems very popular
yeah I mean if people I understand
people who want to do it but I
personally I think that's like the one
surgery it seems to be much more popular
to
do everything but that oh yeah yeah for
sure because I think that's kind of like
the appeal of
you know being with someone that's trans
is
I don't know it's almost you're a whole
new sex exactly because you're not
female you're some hybrid of the two
yeah literally a hybrid that's I've
always said I'm like I'm like a Ken and
Barbie hybrid but and then the what's
interesting I just came back from
Thailand where
there are ladyboys everywhere yeah
everywhere they're accepted yeah it
seems and
it's these ladyboys are perhaps the most
attractive females you'll find yeah
but they have the sex drive of a man
and if you went to any man and said you
know you can have sex with 12 different
women this week exactly they would all
say sure yeah exactly and that's what
that's what you've got you've got a
super attractive woman who wants to have
sex with everything she can yeah and
that was that's honestly me I've
like said I'm like do I have a problem
like I have the craziest high sex drive
and that's how I feel like I've been
able to do this industry so much is
because
once I not I'm like I'm ready again so
yeah
um but yeah I'm very excited to
transition and
um
I don't know just kind of leave
everything behind and it is what it is
and I've I've always said since I was a
kid I want to live life and experience
as much as I can and
um
I know
I might eventually like kind of
I don't know how to explain it I might
like uh
reap what I have sown basically
um with these substances with my health
and stuff in the future but I mean I've
I've have so many crazy experiences so I
guess it's like not all for nothing
um and this is why I always say like
save your money because I am able to
transition out of this and
I know I think I want to get into like
modeling something more clean like I
mean obviously that industry is very
dark too but um can be but like
no snacks anymore for money I'm still
teetering on only fans or not if I want
to continue it
um but I
don't ever film with others on there
it's always just solo content
so and I'm not going celibate that's for
sure but not on like a pay basis if that
makes sense but was this the first time
you fell in love with someone
truly I feel like it is and
I felt like this person was meant to
come into my life
to show me that
um
to kind of almost show them like the
world to kind of show me or the universe
like um
I was just so crazy about this person
and I felt like it was kind of once I'm
out of an hour reflection of
you need to work maybe on yourself a
little more
because you're not ready for a
relationship because I was doing so many
even Beyond like that stuff like illegal
things for this person like
um and like I love Lana Del Rey
um and you know her music's amazing and
I'm not blaming her music on this but I
have always just kind of fantasized
about this like
kind of like Bonnie and Clyde's sort of
relationship where it's like the love is
just like
I will put myself through anything for
someone and I and I'm a very submissive
person so like I felt like
all the time I was like I'm my will to
live is for this person and I'll put up
with anything to just like submit to a
man and
um but I think I took it too far I think
I took it a little too far with some of
the things I was putting myself through
that could have literally ended me up
in terrible places you have to
understand you're only 21 years old
exactly I I have always
I felt like been ahead of myself where
I'm at in life with my compared to my
age
um and I'm like wow like I feel like
I've experienced so much and done so
much as it's a young age it's like I
don't know what the rest like what more
could I possibly you know experience in
the future and that could be concerning
and scary if I continue on you know with
this lifestyle but but I mean I guess I
am happy that I
Found Love even if it was quite
temporary but yeah
it usually is yeah
I'm still in that like sad moment right
now
I think the important thing is that you
were able to pull yourself out of the
hold of the drug exactly and I think
time was of the essence with that I
think if I
um and I am lucky that I have had the
resources and help and you know been
able to get like on antidepressants and
stuff like that which is something I've
you know never been on
um so you're you're on
um
yeah so I am fortunate that I've been
able to do that but I was digmatized for
sure
um that's what I always say like with
this person and it just let down a dark
path
and I want to like help you I really
like my purpose of like for asking to
come back on today was um
to help people who might be in this
situation like um the sooner you just
end
you know this bad um
habits and you this it's never too late
until it is too late if that makes sense
like and I want to help people
kind of just understand that like this
industry is very dark and it can't
swallow you alive and it's best to just
not do it you know
Garrett I'm proud of you for thank you
climbing out of that situation yeah and
I wore my Rick Owens some my thousand
dollar shoes today yeah everyone came
from my dirty Air Force One since last
you got lots of criticism in the
comments about your dirty shoes they
were dirty they just weren't perfectly
white yeah like the Air Force ones are
just so inexpensive I I didn't even
think about you know also it's really
early right now I don't wake up early so
I didn't even notice what she was
putting on well I'm glad you're doing
well yes I look forward to seeing where
you go from here yeah it's only up from
here yeah
yes
all right dear thank you very much